but the other problem we have on the
right and and
i couldn't agree more with everywhere
you said in terms of also the content
selection right this is engaging stuff
our rich guys don't put their money up
whereas the rich guys on the left do
right and i've i've
banged my head again i've had this
argument time and time again with big
donors not just about culture but even
about races you know we just watched an
election go down a lot of frustration at
county levels audits etc
no matter what side you fall down on
that
the fact remains elections are decided
at the county level but you go to the
rnc
you go to big establishment republican
donors you tell them hey look guys soros
out of foxtrot here he's been funding
da's and supervisors of elections
because he understands doesn't matter if
the general presidential or school board
they're the people not only deciding it
or counting it
they're the ones investigating any
impropriety the dems own 99 percent of
them around the country yeah you go to
the rnc with that they look down on you
oh we don't get involved in that we get
no no no we go to the dinner parties in
dc oh god no we drink you know
cappuccino with our pinky out we're not
going to go to some dirty county with
the unwashed mashes and masses and fly
over country that's not what we do at
the rnc
that's why we have joe biden in the
white house
voter engagement voter registry now
florida was different and people don't
tell this story in florida we had a very
robust
grassroots effort
and uh it started a little bit before
the election it continued throughout we
had rick scott who got rid of two
terrible supervisors of elections
bless you bless you desantis continued
that with that they shone a light on a
lot of these problems in in the
elections offices well what happened
story you never hear in the mainstream
media donald trump won florida in 2020
by two and a half times what he did in
2016. doing no small part to those
efforts why because money poured in
money poured in an attention poured in
if we did that around the country we
could move the needle in elections and
if that same money started funding
culture
we could start to move that needle but
again they don't do it so if we're going
to place the blame on we can place it on
conservative content creators not going
in the right direction but we also have
to place the blame on our big money that
refuses to get into the fight they won't
step into the fight there are some
people who think that i can't remember
what i was talking to a while ago and uh
i i consider myself to be fairly
moderate my my idealism brings me to
like left libertarianism but my realism
makes me kind of just a moderate
centrist and
what i was told was they were like the
reason your show works is because you're
not a suit wearing traditional
conservative but you're talking about
freedom you're questioning the
establishment narrative yeah and i think
that actually is a good point when you
look at turning point usa for instance
you know they they they they do a good
job they're extremely effective but
are they cool i'm so sick of seeing red
white and blue sets
because they're just
they're kind of cringy with some of the
stuff that they release but you you
brought up some very important points
because i think there's a reason why
george soros is literally giving over
two million dollars to kim fox in
chicago all right there's a reason why
they're getting involved on such a local
level and the impact of it is right we
we get all that but how come every time
you can have these people on the right
talk about how they understand you're
losing the cultural battle the the left
is funding da's they're getting into the
nooks and crannies in every in every
single way and the right still just has
this culture of being stodgy and
america is an empire which is a big
problem because pro-america and a lot
to a lot of people might mean
pro-imperialism i'm very much for the
constitution what it was meant to
produce but i'm not for the the takeover
of afghanistan in iraq and the
absorption of materials from around the
world military bases i understand you
want to prevent total war and the idea
of limited war
but
i don't like that i don't want to rip up
the united states completely but most
conservatives are going your way i think
most conservatives
are starting to
shift your way i know i am was it uh the
american conservative i think who said
fire john bolton hired tulsi gabbard i
think yeah that was and i'm like yeah
i'll take it and i think most people on
the right well on the america first
right right looked at that and said yeah
yeah okay yeah you're not putting in
charge of economic policy right you're
telling her to stop wasting our money in
afghanistan but are they the majority or
are neoconservatives who are bought out
by the military-industrial complex who
want more conflict who have failed this
country time and time again i think the
bush presidency absolutely destroyed the
republican party and has put a
absolutely disgusting face on the
republican party because it's a party of
corruption it's a party of war it's a
party that will lie to you about wmds
they have lost the trust of middle
america because of that presidency but
luke your question is a great one it
might be one of the most important
questions and i think the answer is
the 2022 republican primaries are going
to answer that question yes the
primaries are everything
because people keep saying i hear i hear
this i hear two things there's going to
be a red wave in 2022 and then people
say and what do republicans do anyway
what's the point and that's why i'm like
go to the primaries
make sure the neocon the establishment
thumb twiddlers or whatever dilly
dollars aren't the ones who are getting
in put support behind the people who you
know and trust who say they're gonna
help this country they're gonna help the
american workers they're gonna have our
borders they're gonna help trade they're
going to bring back jobs not ship them
off to foreign countries
get those guys in the primaries primary
mcconnell lindsey graham like come on
i'll be honest the things you were just
saying it just sounded like rhetoric
well you i almost started to tone out
while you were talking just then bring
back jobs fix the economy like i have
heard that my entire life and it's
meaningless to me no yeah because what
are you specifically going to do are you
going to build a graphic lives on strike
facility in washington dc like give me
some specifics what's your plan right
fusion generators in ohio the famous
story is donald trump going to the auto
manufacturers and saying if you ship
your factories overseas or across the
border i will tax you at 30 and no one
will ever buy your car again put your
factories in america give
seeing
americans
bank accounts overseas under donald
trump's presidency they did bring back
auto plants to michigan and they
invested i think it was like three
billion dollars yeah it was a good
amount a thousand jobs so if people
don't have jobs what happens they end up
unemployed in middle america that the
elites call flyover country and they
start doing opioids they start getting
addicted they have nothing they have
nothing to do anymore nothing to live
for and they go to the hot spot slot
machines and just gamble away doing
nothing people need purpose they need
work if they don't have work they can't
generate revenue purpose and work are
different though you could give a guy a
job and dig a hole i'll say them
separately and another guy to fill the
hole up and now they're busy not looking
at you who's the banker profiting off of
both of them but they both have jobs
it's actually really simple right now
there is an establishment democrats
republicans alike have been extracting
from this country for decades sending
jobs overseas what does that mean it
means that when you get money and then
spend it on a product it goes to a
massive multinational corporation and
then it pays out salaries in foreign
countries the money leaves your
community when there's less money in
your community your community becomes
impoverished and then people fall to
drugs and poverty and crime and cities
start decaying we are seeing small towns
across the country falling apart
populations leaving kids growing up
saying i gotta get out here there's
nothing here for me we need to to
reinvigorate american industry so that
people have work to do and it doesn't
mean archaic you know old technologies
that are pollutants it means new
innovations new technologies but so long
as you have the democrats who say we're
going to jack up the price to hire
workers we're going to then increase the
tax on your corporation but remove all
tariffs you're telling those companies
look if you hire the chinese people who
are going to work for a dollar an hour
and you're not going to pay them health
care we're not going to tax the goods
they produce you are telling them to
extract from this country so we need
republicans i mean i'll take anybody
that's part of party libertarian or
otherwise who is going to say
we need to actually have some policy
some regulation that says we will not
let you extract the value of american
innovation and send it to foreign
countries to profit you are stealing
from the american people when you do
that but i think i think you can even
simplify that and and to both of your
points
we need to distill our messaging all
right right now people are pissed off
they are angry
those primaries i truly believe and i've
been involved in politics
since i was a teenager and throughout
law enforcement i any private sector
company i've been involved in has always
had some kind of regulated product
whether it be firearms or ammo or
something like that
it's simpler than that
we need primary candidates on the right
it's almost neo neo conservatism right
let's you know out with the old in with
the new that first educate america and
they turn america on to the fact
of what you said both parties are
against you yeah they hate you they look
down on you you're nothing you're a surf
you're meaningless to them you're a
worker bee
designed to do the job they're they're
they're the lobbyists who pay them want
you to do to enrich those come so until
you teach americans
that the uniparty the establishment of
both parties are the same people they
hang out at the same parties in in dc
they go to the same parties in hollywood
that you've got to bust because it's a
cartel is what it is and you have to
start liking the dc establishment to one
of the mexican drug cartels it's all it
is right sinaloa and then wars new
generation yeah they kill each other but
at the end of the day they're all
enjoying money from the same pie and
destabilizing the us in the process you
have to educate the people the
candidates that come out punching
and start pointing out leadership you
know what
even if you elect you may like me i
might be america first but if you elect
me and you don't elect more like me then
you're stuck with a kevin mccarthy
speaker who's john boehner and paul ryan
2.0 and 3.0 so give me some support
give me a caucus that can elect the
speaker to move the needle and most
importantly state legislatures people
have got to start learning that their
state legislatures their county
commissions affect their lives far more
than federal politicians do until we
bust the cartel up and we have enough
bodies in there
fighting all of these things are
platitudes what's a good way to get
involved with state legislature
that's the easiest right you just you
can join your county party
and and bring 10 of your like-minded
friends in
kind of be a jerk in there get loud and
move the needle get get rid of the old
entrenched people who've been there for
40 years who have the stain same
establishment candidates that just
assume
they're going to be reelected in the
primary because nobody's going to buck
the system how many states do we need
for a convention of states what do we
mean two thirds 34 i think 36 22 thirds
is it 37 whatever two thirds of 50 yeah
and we have what 35 republicans like 32
and 38 for a vote i think so if we
change the complexion of those
legislatures
we may never even have to move to a
national divorce we might just be able
to put enough fear in these people
that they'll say okay the right is now
serious and it's formidable because
right now we're not the democrats don't
they can steamroll us you made a very
good point and i wanted to kind of add
to it because when you look at the mafia
and the government there's not much
difference no they operate they're
almost the same
thank you exactly look at the fed and
look at the crime hold on private
sanitation
there actually is an important
difference we have a chance to actually
get in and affect government yes we got
to get into the state level now the
mafia i mean you can try and join you
might have better chances with the mafia
i think i'm the only guy in the room
eligible i'm the only full-blown you
have uh you need 34 states to call the
convention in 38 to ratify an amendment
that's perfect so okay
so i don't know how many i think it's
what 35 republican states maybe not that
means if if you can get real america
first state reps in these jurisdictions
and maybe even if having all these
states your republic republican doesn't
guarantee they'll be in favor of this
right but you get a few more states if
people go the state level and vote for
people who actually mean it we could
just have an art was an article 5
convention of states yes
the governors
i think state legislatures
and that's a lot easier to do and then
they can well they can all they can
amend the constitution yeah they can
amend it but you need 38 to ratify but
the point is you don't even need to get
that far the simple fact that they see
this grassroots groundswell starting to
work not just coming but actually
starting to be effective having some
utility
that's when they become very afraid and
that's what if you remember go back to
was the uh bush clinton race
right bush was
uh assumed the winner after he won the
gulf war quickly
uh you know kuwait
was was freed again not that it's free
you get what i'm saying he pushed the
saddam out of kuwait
even one of my professors in college
said george bush just won his
re-election it's done nobody should run
and then bill clinton played the
saxophone on mtv
really right and then what did bush do
oh no i hear you you want change you
want something new he completely pivoted
he threw his 40 some odd years in
politics out the window completely
pivoted but by this point he was playing
catch-up yeah clinton had already you
know opened the gap that was never going
to be closed and entered into ushered in
a new era of politics
but if you put a little fear in the
establishment a little fear
and you start to see
they start to see that the numbers are
moving away from them they'll do what
you want we saw that in 2008 when the
cnn youtube debates happened for the
first time that was we were pushing hard
on youtube 2006 and 7 for just control
of politics as young americans that's
right and they capitulated immediately
and then they put those people but
they've hand selected what questions got
to be seen i asked about the federal
reserve they ignored me but i was a loud
voice in that movement thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you